foreign
and now a group of players that shine
bright on any stage they step on voted
in by fans all over the world Salt Lake
City here are your starters
[Applause]
making his All-Star debuting a
breathtaking breakout season from your
own Utah Jazz The Finisher Lowry
marketing
this dominant score is a four-time
All-Star making his third consecutive
start representing the Boston Celtics
Jason Tatum
one of the most Unstoppable players in
the league making his sixth All-Star
appearance the man in the middle for the
Philadelphia 76ers Joelle embiid
another
five-time All-Star from the Denver
Nuggets leads the league in triple
doubles and is the NBA's reigning
two-time Most Valuable Player nikona
jokic
[Applause]
one of the most electric players in the
game today and now a two-time All-Star
from the Memphis Grizzlies jaw Morant
[Applause]
he's a four-time All-Star a Slam Dunk
champion and a dynamic score for the
Cleveland Cavaliers give it up for
Donovan Mitchell
he's a prolific playmaker an NBA
champion and an eight-time All-Star from
the Dallas Mavericks Kyrie Irving
the League's leading scorer making his
fourth All-Star appearance he does it
all for the Dallas Mavericks Luca
duchess
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
ERS of the pack earning the most
All-Star votes let's welcome your
All-Star captains
[Applause]
[Music]
our game this NBA champion and two-time
League MVP is one of the most dominant
forces in the game a defensive player of
the year and the finals MVP from the
Milwaukee Bucks The Greek Freak Giannis
antetokounmpo
foreign
he's a four-time Kia NBA Most Valuable
Player a four-time champion and a
four-time Finals MVP playing in the
record-breaking 19th All-Star Game the
all-time leading scorer in the NBA
history from the Los Angeles Lakers
LeBron James
[Applause]
fans let's hear it again one more time
for your NBA 2023 All-Stars
[Applause]